a lot of people don't realize this but
in venture capital less than three
percent of the entire venture industry
is black and that's a problem when the
black community represents over 13 of
the population
[Music]
my name is frederick gross i'm a
principal at storm ventures
and i'm also one of the co-founders of
black vc storm ventures
is an early stage b2b focused venture
firm and then black vc
is the largest black venture community
in the united states a big part of it
was me deciding i wanted to be in
venture
for the long haul and with that i was
looking for mentors and i realized
i needed help from folks who'd been
there who'd seen ups and downs in the
venture cycle
and so i was looking for black community
members to help just give me advice
and i realized there was no community
and i thought that was a big
inefficiency and a lot of the people
that helped co-found black vc alongside
me
we all believed there was value to
building community where we could
support one another as black
professionals but also
we believe that by coming together we
could help start to change the way
venture itself had
begun to develop which is to say we
could start to ensure
that diversity was a big part of the
conversation
it's easy in 2020 to think of this as
like a point in time
it really isn't it's the next step in a
conversation a dialogue in a fight
that's been happening for
you know hundreds of years actually in
this country and it's just now
impacting and hitting the business world
which is a big part in my viewpoint
of achieving at least as we think about
it the american dream
i'm the son of a gentleman whose
first job was in a steel mill in ohio
and to be in the heart of silicon valley
in venture capital is just
by definition the american dream and i
feel blessed and lucky that i get to
live that dream
but i also worry that we aren't creating
pathways for more people
that look like me that came from where i
come from to be able to achieve that
dream
the america that i want to see is an
america where the american dream
is something that every american can
look at and know is possible for them
[Music]